it's necessarily true that we will live
under new renewables it's just a
question of when if it's not renewable
that means it's going to run out at some
point and you will have the choice of
collapse of civilization and instead all
cages we go or find something that is
renewable and so you spend your life
admiring people like Elon Musk instead
of going off when doing the thing for
yourself here's the specific action I
want you to take I remember nine years
ago when I started a leap a people say
yet don't touch the financing sector
because it's illegal you may be in
prison rise and shine it's an espresso
time what's up believe nation at seven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent adds something and I want
you to find it embrace it and use it to
make a difference so let's start your
day off right together grab your coffee
and sip on today's message solve big
problems over to you Elon Musk
his interest in our energy crisis
started last year when South Australia a
state already heavily invested in wind
and solar power was plunged into
darkness the result of a massive storm
that saw the state lose power
Elon Musk tweeted headfirst into a
national political brawl when fellow
billionaire Australian IT whiz Mike
cannon Brooks questioned
Tesla's boast that it could help solve
South Australia's energy problems by
building the world's biggest battery why
did you do that
there was no idea of what would happen
afterwards just more if people make big
claims like that I'd like to check if
they're real you thought I was joking
because I had to check that with my team
it's like I hope I I didn't really say
something super crazy when you get a
return tweet from Elon saying yeah what
did you think so wait
just checking his Co sure yeah he says
he's gonna happen and maybe this make it
happen right so these are public tweets
yeah and but in a way that's that's part
of our locks in the guarantee right he's
putting his reputation online in a
public forum there that you know enough
noise was then created around enough
people saw that that it was like alright
but that you know he'd better get that
done more than ever
Australians are struggling to pay for
their power a record number of families
are on hardship plans or deferred
payments and the rate of disconnections
in most states has risen sharply the
Elon Musk learning of this growing power
poverty is overwhelming
cost of power is making it almost a
luxury item Wow
really everybody's that and raus is that
expensive
Australia has so many national resources
I mean even if you go the fossil fuel
route yeah
the electricity should be very cheap
there are Australians today wondering if
they can even turn on their lights
they're Australians today wondering well
should we go without some food sure in
in that's just not something you would
ever expect I did not expect that
yeah bukata
it's necessarily true that we will live
under net renewables it's just a
question of when in fact it's it's it's
it's in the definition that if it's not
renewable that means it's going to run
out at some point and you will have the
choice of collapse of civilization and
into the dark ages we go or find
something that is renewable so all of
this is about saving ourselves yeah
[Applause]
Avilan musk had his way the world would
be totally powered by renewables and
he'd be colonizing Mars he is a
big-picture man with big plans but it
might be his push for the modest lithium
battery will prove to be one of the more
significant steps in this electric
revolution you have been seen as a
catalyst somebody that is showing gosh
there is a there is another way yeah and
that's that's a great thing
people Australia should be should be
proud of the fact that Australia has the
world's biggest battery this is pretty
great and that it will serve as an
inspiration really to the whole world as
well just to say that this is possible
so this is why people love Elon Musk so
much the man is off doing amazing things
he thinks in the big scale he acts on a
big scale he's not afraid of what people
think of him and here's the thing I
think one people love him for all the
good that he's doing in the world but
two people look at him and they love him
because they're insecure with themselves
because you want to do big things
because you will have big ambitions and
big dreams and big goals and you're
afraid to go off and chase them and so
you love people like Elon Musk who are
off doing that because you want to do it
yourself and I want to tell you that you
can because any big idea that you have
at the beginning you don't know how
you're gonna accomplish it it's easy to
look at Elon Musk now and say wow look
this guy is a billionaire is all this
money he's a super genius you know at
the beginning you didn't have a lot of
money at the beginning didn't have the
connections and the resources he just
started and at the beginning of all of
his companies he didn't know how it was
gonna work out he wants to colonize Mars
he still doesn't know how it's gonna
happen he's experimenting he's testing
he's got some theories but there's tons
of holes in his plan you know his
rockets blew up when he was trying to
get into space he had a perfect plan but
it doesn't work out that way and so this
is where I think a lot of people get
held up you have a big dream you have a
big mission you know what you want to
accomplish you know what that ideal
world looks like but because there's so
many holes in your plane you have that
voice in your head that says you can't
do it you don't have the money the
connections the resources the family the
education you
not good enough to be able to go off and
do that big thing and so you spend your
life admiring people like Elon Musk
instead of going off when doing the
thing for yourself so here's what I
challenge you to do I want you to think
about what your mission is I want you to
think about the world that you want to
create like what what is your purpose
what are you trying to do what is so
important to you make it bold make it
powerful make it big and then here's the
specific action I want you to take put
it on the homepage of your website put
it on the homepage of your website when
I threw away my website that was making
me lots of money I am banning the whole
thing and I said I want to solve the
world's biggest problem I just put that
up as a picture my my entire website
which was one of the most popular
websites in the world now just became a
one page landing page picture now it's a
little more fleshed out but it's still
just a bunch of pictures and I said I am
trying to solve the world's biggest
problem untapped human potential join me
and I had no idea what I'm doing
and I still don't know what I'm doing
I'm a little bit closer than I was
yesterday in the day before and the day
before but I don't think this problem
will ever be solved I'm just trying to
make a dent in it and so put that right
up on your homepage your big mission on
your homepage
the big problem you're trying to solve
why one because people are gonna visit
that and they're gonna talk to you about
it they're gonna ask you about it
they're gonna want to know how they can
be involved when you are solving some
big problem when you're on a big mission
people want to be involved with it
because their life sucks too because
they want their life to have meaning
because they have big dreams and
aspirations but they're too afraid to go
off and do it and so they want to be a
part of something special that something
special could be your thing so you want
to put it up so that the more people ask
you about it the more it keeps you
accountable the more it keeps you
motivated you got all these people are
asking you daily what are you trying to
do how can I help it's inspiring to keep
moving forward and then too I would make
sure that your homepage is the default
landing page when you load a browser so
whenever you load Chrome or ie or
Firefox whatever you use you have the
option to set a default website that
default website is your home page that
you
up every time you little browser and you
see your powerful inspiring mission
right there so mine is my face and it
says I'm trying to solve the world's
biggest problem on top human potential I
see that everyday and people write to me
every day around it it helps keep me
focused on the big picture on where I'm
going that little child like I can do
anything as opposed to the responsible
adult little voice inside my head saying
that I can't do it we love looking up to
these great leaders these entrepreneurs
these artists and say wow look at what
they can do and we're in awe of them and
that's great and you should be if they
have talent it's awesome you want to
cheer them on but from a place of
strength not insecurity because you're
worried that you can't do it that you
never will that you have untapped
potential inside you that you don't
think you can ever realize you can you
seem to make a commitment to doing it
put it up on your website look at that
page every single day let's start making
some magic happen now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question
today I want to know what is the big
problem that you are trying to solve
step number one before you go and make
your website and change the homepage is
put it in the comments make your
resounding statement you don't need to
wait for your website to go up let's
share it
right now declare the belief nation what
your big problem is that you are going
to try to solve that's the mark you're
gonna make on the world leave it in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
[Music]
you
we are not a company that normally China
corn we call ourself accompanied running
a platform a company that is running an
ecosystem we are almost everywhere
people say jack you know you are in the
b2b and b2c and you're calling c2v on a
finance and online payment logistic
cloud computing you are everywhere
not because we're greedy not because we
want to do it because we have to do it
if we cannot if we do not do it
China ecommerce in the years were
collapse
I remember nine years ago when I started
that alley pay people say yes don't
touch the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison and I we
taught our self if we don't do it the
China e-commerce were always like a like
a chat room everybody said it's a good
thing and yeah I don't pay you don't get
the things so I say well put me in the
prison let's make a shirt that Ali pay
the payment solution works and people
said the payment solution is such a
stupid idea it's an escrow service I pay
you hold the money and you get the
things you pay the money if you don't
get the things you want
return the money they say it's a stupid
product and I say as long as you solve
the problem
I like stupid things you know let's make
stupid things smart keep on improving
every day I like to say my management
style is problem solver and chief and so
what I do in a given day is I have a set
of problems that need to be solved and I
started the most important and work my
way down and for the problems I don't
have time for somebody else gets to
solve them now if somebody's already
solving another problem of solving a
problem I need to get involved the
problems getting solved but you know
people go wow so your days just full of
problems I'm like yeah I've got a lot of
problems but but it's sort of like how a
math professor thinks of problems right
is that think of a great math professor
who has no math problems to solve
he's a very sad man
and so that's very much how I look at it
solving problems is a you know every
problem is an opportunity for innovating
and being creative and finding something
new and that's what I love to do and I
do it every day
altruistic world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think unseen it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what gary vee DJ khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video